ce que je vois à travers de tous les
déplacements que les formes dans toute
la france ces deux choses la première
c'est que les français c'est évidemment
veulent pas de monsieur mélenchon
premier ministre mais ils veulent pas
non plus que monsieur malraux décide
tout seul et où tous les comme c'était
le cas ces sympathiques et donc
contrairement à l'élection présentielle
que je sais pertinemment qu'un certain
nombre de nos électeurs ont voté mâcon
pour éviter mélenchon le pen au deuxième
tour la plus ancienne là c'est pas
pareil le motive cette fois ci c'est
voter pour les républicains parce qu'on
évite mélangeant premier ministre et on
évite macron avec exactement la même
attitude que ces cinq dernières années
le vote utile c'est voter pour détecter
les cas et je veux aussi vous dire que
le vote utile ceci un vote efficace pour
plus autorité pour plus de sécurité les
peines minimum pour les agresseurs de
policiers de gendarmes de pompiers vous
demain nous sommes les seuls à porter
cette mesure qui change radicalement les
choses parce qu'enfin ce qui nous
protège seront pas touchés de la même
façon sur le pouvoir d'achat il peut pas
oublier la valeur travail
le texte en préparation
s'apprête notamment à ce que les
salariés les artisans les commerçants
les agriculteurs et professions
libérales soit oublié mais n'en est pas
question
si on veut demain à l'assemblée
nationale que l'autorité que la valeur
travail que la prise en compte de la
dette qu'il faut faire reculer soit
garanti il n'y a que les députés
républicains qui pourront le faire parce
qu'on voit bien qu'il soir du premier
tour
on a aujourd'hui un pouvoir qui nouvelle
à gauche toute alors qu'on sait bien
tout ce sont les valeurs de la droite
les idées de la droite qui sont celles
de votre pays a besoin c'est la raison
pour laquelle je vraiment
aujourd'hui aux sélections du satim
voter utile ces modèles
[Musique]